pourquoi le vrai pour l'égalité hommes
femmes au sein du département de la
vienne
nous avons choisi de poursuivre la
démarche engagée déjà depuis le début du
mandat par les actions dès le plus jeune
âge avec nos services de protection
maternelle et infantile également au
sein des collèges par des actions
culturelles au niveau du sport
ensuite depuis la mise en place du
conseil départemental des jeunes
nous allons travailler avec eux sur ce
thème le département siège également au
groupement d'intérêt public enfants ses
dangers le 39 19 qui participent
activement à la prévention et à la
protection des enfants notamment dans le
cadre des violences au sein du couple
nous souhaitons également poursuivre
notre soutien aux associations qui
interviennent directement auprès des
femmes victimes de violences par de
l'accueil de l' écoute et de
l'orientation par ces différentes
actions le conseil départemental
s'engage pleinement pour la défense des
droits des femmes
plusieurs points aujourd'hui pour
favoriser l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes au sein du conseil
départemental
le premier s'est structuré la démarche
puisque la collectivité va mettre en
place le rapport social unique dès 2021
selon la loi sur la transformation de la
fonction publique également un référent
dédié sur la question de l'égalité
hommes femmes et la lutte contre les
discriminations sera identifiée sur la
collectivité dès 2021 point c'est de
continuer à recruter et former sans
discriminer pour que la collectivité
s'engage à définir les conditions de
formation compatible avec les
obligations familiales ou personnelles
de chaque agent de la collectivité et
également pour les femmes les moins
qualifiés collectivités s'engagent
également à communiquer bien sûr les
modifications sur concernant la durée du
congé de paternité qui va être modifiée
dès le 1er juillet 2021 avec 28 jours le
dernier point sensibiliser mobiliser
responsabilise
et avec une campagne d'affichage dans
l'ensemble des locaux de la collectivité
pour sensibiliser les agents sur les
propos sexistes et enfin la collectivité
s'engage et continue en 2021 auprès de
tous les agents sur la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
8 mars
est ce la journée de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes le 25
novembre
[Musique]